[Musique]
et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
avec souad baba aïssa vice-présidente de
la dalle à l'errance des démocrates de
la diaspora algérienne bonsoir madame
merci d'être avec nous en direction des
france à vos côtés le général dominique
trinquant expert en géostratégie ancien
chef de la mission militaire française
auprès de l'onu bonsoir général
trinquant remercie également d'être avec
nous alors je le disais en introduction
c'est donc une petite phrase emmanuel
macron dans les colonnes du magazine
jeune afrique qui a donc fait polémique
de l'autre côté de la méditerranée je
vous propose de regarder d'abord je vous
le dis franchement je ferai tout mon
possible pour aider le prise d'antenne
boon dans cette période de transition
il est courageux on ne change pas un
pays des institutions et des structures
de pouvoir en quelques mois il faut tout
faire pour que cette transition
réussisse je ferai tout mon possible
pour aider le président est bonne c'est
cette phrase souad ben aissa qu'ils ne
passent pas expliqué nous écoutez moi je
voudrais dire que je n'aurais pas la
vision étroite d'un nationalisme qui dès
qu'une personne s'exprime sur l'algérie
crie à l' ingérence mais je me pose que
là nous sommes pas un président de la
république française qui fait vraiment
une immixion est vraiment une immixion
qu'on appellerait plutôt une ingérence
politique en disant qu'il apporte tout
son soutien à monsieur tebboune qui est
un président qui a été nommé par un
système politique que ce système
politique est entièrement refusé par le
peuple algérien qui est dans la rue
depuis le 12 février 2019
le 22 février 2010 9 mm avant et qui dit
bien qu'il veut un changement politique
et monsieur teboul n'a pas la figure n'a
pas le visage de quelqu'un qui
représente cette transition démocratique
puisque les élections du 12 décembre
2019 ont rejeté le scrutin
c'est un homme qui a été nommé par à
pouvoir politique et le pouvoir
militaire puisque nous savons que dans
ce pays
en tout cas nous avons une armée à qui
appartient le pays et que cet état il ce
peuple lui cette armée qui est là et qui
l'empêchent d'avancer et de changer
politiquement et quand il dit qu'il
apporte tout son soutien à monsieur
tebboune dans cette transition
nous aimerions savoir de quelle
transition il parle parce que les
élections liés à cette espèce de à ce
pseudo référendum sur un changement de
constitution a été aussi rejeté par le
peuple
et ce n'est pas avec un pourcentage de 4
% d'électeurs on arrive à assortir un
pourcentage de 66 % de oui au référendum
est de faire croire à un plébiscite
donc ne nous avons consciemment pris
cette phrase en main parce qu'elle
démontre que aujourd'hui ce pouvoir a
peur et qu'il est en train de chercher
des légitimités et que monsieur le
président de la république française
emmanuel macron est en train d'apporter
de la légitimité à un pouvoir qui ne
doit pas en avoir
alors que depuis son arrivée il y à une
répression incroyable et on en reparlera
je pense tout au long de ce débat on va
en parler effectivement soit de bailly
ça quand on écoute les propos assez bien
expliquée de votre interlocutrice
général train quand le contexte algérien
on a suivi ici même sur cette antenne
alors que cet ancien fidèle david aziz
bouteflika n'est pas très apprécié des
algériens on peut comprendre quand même
n'hésite imité dans cette colère que
emmanuel macron a fait un revirement
maintenant je pense que je pense qu'il
faut aller jusqu'où re au bout des mots
et le mot de transition est très
intéressant si le président macron à
utiliser le mot de transition c'est
qu'il sait que l'algérie est dans une
phase de transformation et
qu'actuellement le président teboul et
représentants de cette transition
on est si vous voulez en algérie un
petit peu comme dans le cas au liban si
vous me permettez
deux révolutions qui sont d'ailleurs
très respectable qui en algérie en
particulier se sont très bien passées
avec des manifestations pacifiques sur
la place qui contestent le pouvoir en
place qui a amené d'ailleurs un
changement en algérie à ce moment-là
peut-être pas à la hauteur de ce que
souhaitait les gens qui manifestaient
dans la rue mais le problème c'est que
la manifestation dans la rue ne débouche
pas sur une proposition sur un parti qui
puisse prendre le pouvoir et changer
radicalement les choses donc aujourd'hui
eh bien écoutez le pouvoir il est ce
qu'il est il est parfaitement
contestable je comprends madame qui le
contestent ce que je veux dire
simplement c'est que il est celui là
aujourd'hui et le président la crau part
d'un pouvoir de transition
parce qu'il a la france a besoin de la
stabilité en algérie pour des tas de
raisons aussi bien à cause de ce qui se
passe au sud de l'algérie que ce qui se
passe à l'intérieur de l'algérie voit de
ce qui se passe en france 2 qu'elle veut
elle a besoin de stabilité
maintenant c'est aux algériens de
changer le le gouvernement et l'espace
politique
or j'ai l'impression je le répète que
c'est comme au liban il ya des
manifestations mais qu'elles ne
débouchent pas sur des changements soin
de soi de baba aïssa pourquoi le mot
quand même d'un g oui alésien les et je
vous en prie répondrais oui oui je vais
répondre justement alors je veux bien
entendre le mot transition changer la
nation transformation ya une différence
entre transformation si j'étais dans un
état démocratique
or nous quand on utilise le mot
transition ça veut dire que monsieur le
président de la république française
emmanuel macron considère que monsieur
tebboune et son gouvernement sont le
visage de la transition
or si je suis dans un état de droit et
que je suis dans un mouvement de
soulèvement populaire et révolutionnaire
la transition passe par un processus de
constituante
il me semble pas puisque comme le dit
monsieur emmanuel macron qu' il faut du
temps pour changer les institutions
pourquoi voulez vous comme
un des noms émergent un parti politique
alors que c'est un pays qui a souffert
dans les années 90 du terrorisme
islamiste et qui a souffert depuis
soixante ans de ce conte son opposition
soient toujours muselé et nous savons
très bien que si il émerger une
quelconque personne
tout de suite il y aurait de la
répression puisque d'ailleurs ce qui se
passe actuellement
depuis ce mouvement révolutionnaire et
depuis que monsieur tebboune est aux
manettes c'est que des jeunes sont mis
en prison
monsieur emmanuel macron qui se vante
d'être le chantre de la liberté
d'expression ne rappelle pas à celui
qu'il considère être son homologue
d'avoir le respect de la liberté
d'expression alors que à 4 et 4 ris nous
n'eûmes est en prison alors que des
journalistes des médecins des citoyens
et des citoyennes lambda sont en prison
et que dans un pays comme la france où
l'on parle de laïcité on à monsieur
yacine mebarki qui a eu dix ans de
prison pour apologie à la laïcité
est-ce que nous sommes dans un état de
droit est ce qu'on peut parler on sait
où on va laisser répondre justement
général train kong avait pas l'air très
d'accord général
non pas du tout parce que c'est ce que
vous dites madame si vous demandez au
président macron à ce moment là de faire
de l'entrisme sur la politique
algérienne à ce moment là on pourra
l'accuser
effectivement mais aujourd'hui les
cartes sont dans les mains du peuple
algérien et si le peuple algérien ne
peut pas changer le gouvernement en
faisant des manifestations sur la place
que voulez vous qu'il fasse le président
français il va pas soulever la
population curieuse on n'a pas demandé
au président français ce que lui a dit
c'est étonnant pardonnez-moi jeu
j'essaye d'apporter de l'eau au moulin
de buzz départ mais c'est vrai de
proposer de l'aide
manuel macron le fais pas pour chaque
pays il ya des intérêts peut-être
géostratégique enjeu important trop la
france et l'algérie allait venir
j'allais y venir
nous savons très bien que l'algérie est
un pays où la géostratégie avec assaël
g5 comme on l'appelle entre la
mauritanie le mali le sahara occidental
et cetera la libye la tunisie le maroc
nous savons très bien qu'il y a des
intérêts géostratégiques et aujourd'hui
ses intérêts géostratégiques ne s'arrête
pas qu'au gaz et au pétrole
ils ont ils vont même plus plus loin
puisque c'est quand même la raie aux
frontières de tout ce qui pourra qui
pourrait arriver en france comme
l'immigration clandestine
donc vous voyez que c'est les armes
c'est tout ce qu'il ya de ce côté là
d'un point de vue géostratégique qui ne
s'arrête pas simplement à l'économique
et ça c'est du président macro parce que
la géostratégie la sécurité de la france
et le c'est la mission première du
président mâcon là est la politique
extérieure de l'algérie et le g des
citoyens algériens
madame qu'un produit est aussi et la
politique étrangère aussi est aux
algériens et aux algériennes elles ne se
paie pas simplement dans les salons à
l'elysée et au quai d'orsay
derrière le dos et les intérêts des
algériens et des algériennes à oran
algérie ça fait bondir comme vous sur ce
bateau char madame regarder ce qu'on dit
notamment le président du rassemblement
pour la culture et la démocratie à
morzine benabbad sur sa page facebook
emmanuel macron s'exerce administrer des
leçons de démocratie et de gouvernance
ils se croient autorisés à distribuer
des certificats de légitimité aux
dirigeants des indigènes que nous sommes
ceci n'est pas une simple ingérence mais
la révélation que la france est aux
manettes d'une feuille de route pour
notre pays
général train quand vraiment vous ne
comprenez pas cette voix lasse on dit on
dit tout et n'importe quoi
madame monsieur
accuse le président d'ingérence madame
demande au président d'intervenir sur la
politique algérienne
ce qui serait de la différence je
rappelle que la politique algérienne
c'est aux algériens de la régler et la
france à ses intérêts géostratégiques
guillard ne transformez pas mes propos
je n'ai jamais demandé à monsieur
emmanuel macron de s'ingérer dans la
politique algérienne
je lui ai demandé justement de ne pas
porter son son soutien à un président
qui est illégitime et que tout un peuple
refuse parce que de toute façon nous
sommes aujourd'hui avec un pouvoir
politique qui n'a pas changé depuis 60
ans c'est le même système politique et
qui est soutenu aujourd'hui sous des
travers néocolonialistes et non pas
colonialiste comme il y a quelques
années et que ce néocolonialisme les
algériens et les algériennes ne sont pas
prêts à l'accepter et que leur cible
s'il ya une ingérence qui l'aurait
apaire c'est peut-être une ingérence et
de rappeler à son homologue qu'il doit
respecter à qu'il doit respecter ce que
réclame un puck quand il demande à un
système politique de double en cire le
peuple qui s'exprime dans la rue aux
quais et le peuple est en train de se
préparer
il n'est pas besoin des manifestations
on ne le voit pas beaucoup ailleurs en
algérie cinq ans s'il vous plaît merci
beaucoup
juste dire que les discussions étaient à
propos d'une ingérence je ne bois pas
d'ingérence dans ce qu'a dit le
président macron bien au contraire
et quant au gouvernement algérien c'est
aux algériens de décider s'il décide
qu'il n'est pas légitime qui change de
gouvernement mais c'est pas la france de
s'en occuper et mérite il n'a pas
soutenu président illégitime tout
simplement mes recettes des douanes a
bien compris vos deux points de vue et
c'est ça qui est intéressant puisque
c'était en face à face donc merci à vous
soit de baba aïssa vice présidente de
l'adar général dominique trinquant
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france merci à vous deux